[Music]
let's go to uh chris in fargo
north dakota what's up brother chris
not much are you doing don't know
i'm all right my man how we doing this
morning
sorry oh you're you're good man
you're good
i got nothing but time my man
okay what's up
actually do this for me take a take as
deep a breath as you can and hold it
now let it out
and those shoulders your shoulders are
up around your ear drop them as low as
you can okay
okay
cool and one more thing
take your hands and squeeze them
together as tight as you can
and count backwards squeeze them as
tight as you can five
four
three
two
all right what's up man
why was my son
about a month and a half ago
oh what was his name i'm a
jesse
how old are you
12.
oh my gosh
um
and i'm a
volunteer firefighter
and i responded thank god no really
dude i'm so sorry
i'm sorry across the board i'm sorry a
thousand different ways man
i have a 12 year old little boy
and i've
my
my guts just left my body
as you said that i'm sorry man
so i'm guessing if you responded then um
was it an emergency was it an accident
what happened
he was
at the neighbor's house
and a friend of the neighbor
was taking him
to pick up
his
daughter
and
i wasn't there
my wife was there
and she didn't know he had been drinking
that much and they were on a side by
side atv
and they crashed
oh my gosh
chris i'm so sorry man
tell me about jesse
tall kid short kid fast short
short kid
tell me about him no skinny he was a
skinny little guy small one of the
smallest kids in his class yeah
funny kid loud annoying silly
tell me about
him very
it was funny
to the point where he thought he was
funnier than he actually was
thought he was
um
he
got along with all the adults
everybody loved him
yeah
he
you could talk about things that
like sign stuff to the adults and they
just be
blown away by him oh he's brilliant huh
yes very smart
what did he love
what did he love
he loved taking things apart
it drove me nuts
what's the worst thing you ever took
apart
we just buy him he
would buy him something
and then within three days he would take
it apart oh he was that kid
yeah yeah
you get him like a vcr or something he
takes it not vcr because it's not the
20th century but yeah get him an xbox
instead of playing it he takes it apart
see how it works wow
yeah exactly
so
you lost your son
you lost your life as you know it
everything's different now
and
my son lost a light in his life
because the lights went out didn't it
like i'm saying like as another kid
who's 12 they were gonna grow up and
create the new world together
and a light went out right
yep
so all the way across the country in
nashville tennessee i want you to know
my heart's broken with you
and that doesn't bring your kid back and
that doesn't make you hurt less but i
want you to know you're not you're not
heartbroken alone
i'm so sorry man
and i'm sorry that you responded to that
i'm sorry that
that shouldn't have happened
procedurally that shouldn't have
happened um that's probably just the
kind of guy you are though as you show
up
even when they tell you don't come you
show up
and well i didn't know what was going on
oh wow okay
i was home
before the call
you know
we carry a pager and when the call comes
out we just go to the station yeah and i
had an idea
it came out as a
personal injury accident
oh it didn't come out as a 1087
no yeah we don't use 10 codes oh you
don't okay
and so i just
went to the station
i jumped on the front right seat
went to the
call i had an idea where it was
and it didn't make sense in life that's
a side road that's
that's uh
how is there an accident there
and
we turned down the street it was about
three blocks away from my house
and
the driver said was that wasn't that
your wife
and i said i didn't see her and we get
closer to the scene and
i started to recognize
two of the people there
and
that's when i started to panic a little
bit because i knew what was going i knew
he was over at the neighbor's house
and there's my neighbor and one of his
friends
they heard the sirens they ran up there
so when i pull up i see those two i jump
out
and
i just kind of forgot everything that i
was supposed to do
and one of the guys grabbed me and
before i could get close to the scene
and just pulled me into the back of the
truck and sat me down
and then that's when the sheriff came
over and told me what happened
whoever that that partner was of yours
um did a heroic thing and i'm glad they
did that
he's amazing yeah that's an amazing man
right there um
a month and a half ago man
so how can i help you man i i want to
hug you you're not here you want to hug
you i'm trying to
wipe in tears of my own away here on the
show and that doesn't happen for me
um
man
i've shown up the scenes i remember i
know that call when your heart starts
beating faster because you think
something's wrong and then all sudden
you know something's wrong
um
i've had to be that guy that pulled the
parent back and said you don't you don't
need that in your head um
and i've had man all that whole thing
oh
geez man even though i wasn't at i
didn't see him it doesn't matter i know
i know i still get flashes of i know
i know i know
i know
can i tell you something that's going to
sound crazy
he's not hurting right now
so much of our head wants to go back to
that moment
he's not hurting right now he's at peace
right now
okay
and if there's if there's no other piece
in your heart right now
he's not scared anymore he's not hurting
anymore he's still
that's the dollar
okay sorry it's a dollar stick man
so i get the
i go call
to my truck and i
go up to the
next street and i
either take a right to go to the fire
station
or i go straight
and i just respond to the scene
and i listen to my procedures
and i took that right
i feel like i failed twice
because i
as
one as a father
example i don't
be with that guy
and
i feel like
i failed him as a firefighter because i
didn't go straight
and just be with him until he passed
away
and if you've ever listened to
heard a word come out of my mouth i'll
tell you your feelings are real and
they're very very important
and they serve a purpose
and our feelings lie to us
the very first way you explained what
happened the words out of your mouth
where i wasn't there
and i should have stopped you then i
didn't
there's no possible way that you would
think
in your neighborhood
that a friend of yours would let your
kid get behind the wheel of an atv with
a drunk driver
any any any more likelihood that you're
it would be your fault if your kid got
struck by lightning
walking down the street
so i get the impulse to feel like i'm
dad i have one job that's to keep my
kids safe and i failed it i get that
impulse i have that same exact impulse
but you're gonna have to open your hands
on that one because that's not on you
okay it's on
the
heart of a guy who was intoxicated and
got behind the wheel of a vehicle and
invited a child along with him
the other thing is i get the impulse as
a first responder
but that that moment of failure that's
not for him
you feel like you failed yourself
yeah
and you didn't
and i also know i can tell you that over
and over and over and your body's going
to respond as your body's going to
respond okay it's going to take
it's going to take seasons for you this
to pass
not to pass this won't the whole thing
won't pass you'll remember this for the
rest of your life it's now part of you
i'm saying you will come to peace with
the fault part of this this is my fault
this is not my fault
okay
you're a damn good firefighter
you signed up you volunteered for crying
out loud you didn't get paid for this
you do this because this is who you are
your community is better because you do
this
and the fantasy that if i just gone
straight i would have had one more
second i get that i get that and it's
not true
because that fantasy turns into and i
probably would have done the one thing
that fill in the blank right
so how can i help you now my guess is
you're in the black hole man the food
taste food tastes different when you
even bother to eat love feels
everything's off
yeah
it's slowly getting better
i'm back to
my full-time job now
but you're just going through the
motions right
yes yeah
yeah
yeah right
that's completely 100
right
okay
king of distractions now whatever i can
fight to distract myself that's fine
um
pardon me
i don't know i don't know what
what to expect i don't know
i hate feeling this way but i also don't
want to give it up i know
because now your son's no longer in your
arms and he's transferred to your pain
and you think if you stop hurting
or if you smile a little bit or if you
have some joy that he's going to go
or that somehow sharing a meal with your
wife
and you all just exhaling for the first
time in a month and a half is somehow
dishonoring to him and it's not
life won't go on life is different now
things won't get back to the way they
were things are different now
there will be a creation of a new and it
will take a while
and so anybody telling you to rush this
process you need to cut them out of your
life
okay okay
you lost your heartbeat
right
yep
i have another son
sir
i lost one of my heartbeats i have
i
hey
another son there you go
and you're gonna walk past that bedroom
and it's gonna be empty and your whole
body's gonna fall apart
and you're gonna pull up to a pizza
place and you're gonna say table for
four it's just gonna pop out of your
mouth and then you're gonna break down
crying in a way that you
thought you'd cried all the tears you
got and nope i got more
all right
or someone's gonna be trying to be kind
and they're going to say something
that in your situation is insensitive
even though they're being lovely how
many kids you got
and your first impulse is going to be
two and you're gonna say one you're
gonna say well i mean i and then the
whole
thing right happened yesterday yeah my
older son
i just
i don't i don't even know what to expect
anymore or
emotionally
okay here's what i'm gonna do
you're not gonna remember a lot of this
um
i'm gonna give you four or five things
okay
and we will cut this out and we'll send
it to you
before it's even edited and all that
kind of you know glossed over and
mastered or whatever they do to it to
make it pretty just so you have these
things now you don't have to wait
another month for it to come out okay
okay
here's thing number one
you cannot do this by yourself
i don't care how tough you are i don't
care how you know fargo you are i don't
care how firemen you are you gotta have
other people you gotta have other people
that you say i'm not doing okay today
today's a today's a black hole day
and they're not gonna try to fix you
they're gonna hug you
they're gonna go get coffee
they're gonna show up with a donut
they're gonna show up with some dinner
and they're not going to say much
they're just going to sit on your porch
with you do you have that
yes i am okay yes
your only job
is to not isolate let them do the rest
okay
okay you might tell them here's what i
need
if i call you you five guys if i call
you here's what i'm looking for
i'm looking for you just to say that
sucks i'm heartbroken
i'm looking for you to send me a picture
of my son that you might have on your
phone i'm looking for you just to
come over with some tacos
okay
that's number one number two
grief is like a fingerprint it's
different for every single person
and yours is going to be different than
your wives and this is why many many
couples who experience what you've
experienced don't make it
because they start holding each other to
impossible standards and they're so mad
and so angry and so frustrated and so
heartbroken that they just lash out at
the closest person to him that happens
to be their wife or their husband
or they say things like i can't believe
you're already back at work how can you
even breathe i can't believe you went to
the gym
i can't even get out of bed
and so i want you and your wife
to commit to having regular
probably every other day check-ins with
one another
and a whole lot of grace
because you're gonna have good days and
bad days on different days
and one of you is gonna have a bad day
and the other person's gonna be having a
good day
and the person who's having a bad day
has to have the courage
and the bravery to say
go have your good day
because bringing another bringing
somebody from their good day down to
your bad day doesn't make you a bad day
better
okay
but you and your wife are gonna have to
create a new language that you did not
have before
okay
yeah
and you're gonna have to decide we need
to learn spanish because we gotta learn
a different way to talk because we can't
talk english anymore in this house
that's that's where you gotta look at it
okay
okay
you have to remember to do the basic
life things like eat
and move
and turn your screens off
okay yeah
and you're gonna have to learn this is
the hard one you're gonna have to sleep
and you've if you've ever listened to
this show you know how against sleep
meds i am i'm okay in a season
okay to get something to get off the
doctor prescribe me something i'm trying
to get off of okay just go to melatonin
right now okay i um i i have
i've never talked about this publicly
but we're in it now um
i will send you personally um a i've got
a substantial discount code with the
only supplement company that i use
they're called thorn and they are
pharmaceutical grade they're the best of
the best of the best and i've got a
significant discount code that i'll send
you and i'll send you the personal sleep
stuff that i use from them
okay they're just a supplement it's not
a it's not a narcotic or anything like
that
it's what i use and everybody's got a
little bit of a tinkering difference
whether it's farm gap at 250 or whether
it's iso or whatever the thing is right
um
but getting some supplement help for
sleep is is wise right now
okay
having some sort of i'm going for a walk
having some sort of i'm gonna go
exercise having some sort of something
and you may go to the gym
and then turn on and go home because
it's not happening that day that's okay
all right
[Music]
don't here's the other one do not over
compensate with your child with your
other son
okay okay
but your other son's gonna have his own
unique grief
the last thing we want to do is have him
feel like he's responsible for making
sure mom and dad's okay
yeah he gets to be here
he gets to be a little boy
yeah right
and he's also gonna say things like i
feel like all you talk about is jesse
that's fine how old is he
he's 15. he's exactly he's 15.
right there's a reason we don't let him
drive yet
so he's gonna have his comments and
that's all fine and good his life
everything about his life is different
now
okay
here's the last one and this one's heart
this one's real hard
how long have you been doing volunteer
fire department stuff
all 15 years though okay
so i'm talking to um somebody who's
responded and seen their fair share of
stuff right
i've been pretty fortunate but
yeah okay i've been to a couple calls
been a couple calls
yeah i have two and here's what i can't
do like when i
i call it the lightning bolt when the
lightning bolt pops into my head out of
nowhere
of some guy who
shot and killed himself and this is
disaster
or some car wreck scene that i showed up
to some sort of something the lightning
bolt pops into my head and the moment
that lightning bolt pops into my head
with that picture or that thought
i have a choice
am i going to meditate on that picture
and go down that rabbit hole and my
heart rate will get up and my body will
flood itself with cortisol and
adrenaline just like i was back on that
scene in real
and i'll start thinking about it and
i'll think about what i said and what i
could have said and what i should have
said and i can't believe i did this and
that one guy took a swing at me because
i was telling him that his wife had like
all those things
i can do that
and when i do that
i'm choosing two things to be more
miserable and to dishonor
the person who passed away
here's the other thing i can do
when that lightning bolt pops into my
head which i cannot control it just does
i don't understand it it happens in the
shower it happens at church it happens
all kind of random places that you just
think of a thing
i can hold my breath for two to four
seconds
i can
exhale and i can intentionally put
another picture in my head
in your case one of walking into a room
and seeing the brand new xbox you just
bought jesse all taken apart
or the time he made y'all laugh at
dinner and you were laughing so hard you
were crying
or a moment like
uh i started crying like a moment ahead
a night ago when my 12 year old walked
through the room and said something and
walked into the other room
and i thought to myself i didn't know i
could love like that
you get to replace that scene
you get to replace that little picture
you have in your head of just his shoe
of all the people crowding around
all the lights you get to replace those
pictures him in the casket
you get to replace all those pictures
with something beautiful
with something of a memory of this
memory of joy and here's what will
happen
those flashes those lightning bolts
that's your brain trying to remind you
that there's scary crap out there you
don't need that reminder it's just your
brain trying to take care of you okay
okay
what we're going to do over time is
we're going to shift our default
settings so that when we think of jesse
we smile first
we don't instantly get transported back
to the worst possible moment of our
entire lives
it's a but listen it's a practice you're
gonna practice and you're gonna find
yourself 15 minutes into a thought
exercise and you're gonna have to call
yourself out on it
i will yell in my home
no
stop
i will do all sorts of wild things to
stop those tracks as they get going
and i've never lived what you've lived
through
the pull will be magnetic
and here's one more final final thing
your son is not in your pain
okay he's in your heart he's in your
hearts he's in those kids in the class
that he was friends with
he was in
the bodies and minds and spirits of
those he made laugh like crazy
he's there man
he's not in your home where he should be
and he's not in his bed where he should
be
but he's not hurting anymore either
do you believe me
yeah okay
anytime you ask yourself what should i
do now
just be right where you're at
okay there's not a playbook moving
forward man other than take care of
yourself be with people love your wife
love your other son
okay
all right
um
there will come a season when you make
meaning of this
okay there'll come a season when
you're now what
i'm gonna start speaking to high school
kids about drunk driving i'm gonna start
um a ministry at my church showing up
when people lose a young one i'm gonna
right that season will come that
season's not today
okay
that's not i gotta go do a thing no you
don't
your body's bleeding from the inside out
and you gotta take a season to heal
going through the motions is right
your family still gotta eat right you
still got to go to work you got to go
through the motions you got to be busy
distraction's fine all those things are
fine until you start distracting with a
recliner and 24 7 netflix and alcohol
and right then the distractions become
unsafe but right now dude you are in
survival mode and that's fine
and anybody who tells you otherwise they
probably lose your
their voice in your life for a while
is that cool
yeah
now listen to me carefully before i let
you go
you're a great dad
you're a great neighbor
and you're a great firefighter
and you lost your son and i'm sorry
thank you
i love you chris and anything we can do
to help you along the way let me know
okay
um and when the show's over before i
head out of here i'll send you the link
to the stuff okay
okay
thank you all right my brother um
thank you for being brave and for
sharing your story with us and
just know there's millions of us that
are heartbroken with you
thank you so much my man thank you thank
you thank you